LET ME GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
RULES COMMITTEE MEETING OF
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH TO ORDER.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS FAITH MINING
HERE MONNING HERE RAFI RAFI
HERE WILL PRESENT WILK HERE
ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND I UNDERSTAND
SENATOR BASE WILL BE HERE TODAY
SHE HAD A- A MEDICAL SITUATION
SO. I THINK SHE BROKE HER FOOT
I DON'T KNOW IF. WHEN I SAY
MEDICAL SITUATION THAT REQUIRES
ME TO AT LEAST SAY IT'S- NOT
AN- INCREDIBLY SERIOUS BUT
WE'RE SORRY THAT SHE'S NOT ABLE
TO JOIN US AND HOPE. THAT SHE'S
GONNA BE OKAY AND BACK SHORTLY
I HAVEN'T SAID THAT WE WILL
MOVE ON AND WHAT I WOULD LOVE
TO DO IF AT ALL POSSIBLE IS
ESTABLISH A CONSENT AGENDA. AND
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT WERE
ABLE TO ACCEPT ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM THREE
BILL REFERRALS ITEM FOR. A
SELECT COMMITTEE ESTABLISHMENT
FOR ANA UNDER UNDER SENATOR
GALGIANI. OF. FLOOR KNOWLEDGE
MINTS ITEM FIVE AND SIX. SO
MOVED THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES MONNING. THANK
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH I WILL HI
WILK AYE ATKINS HI THAT COMES
ON SO THAT PASSES FOUR ZERO
WITH SENATOR BATES ABSENT. LET
ME I'LL GO AHEAD AND INVITE UP.
OUR GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO APPEAR DR BORAN
STEEN MISS LESLEE AND MISTER
OLSON IF YOU'LL COME ON UP AND-
GET SITUATED. WELCOME I AS A
COURTESY TO ONE OF OUR SENATE
COLLEAGUES I'M GONNA INVITE.
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON UP
SHE WANTS TO MAKE ONE
INTRODUCTION AND I BELIEVE AND
WILL IT TAKE YOU FIRST AND THEN
MOVE INTO THEIR OPENING
STATEMENTS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
ACTUALLY SERVED ON RULES BEFORE
SO THIS IS SORT OF AN
INTERESTING VIEW. BUT I AM HERE
AND VERY PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
MY FRIEND AND CONSTITUENT DAVID
OLSON I HAVE KNOWN MISTER OLSON
SINCE ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WHEN HE BECAME THE C. E. O. OF
PATAGONIA ONE OF THE GREAT A
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE COMPANIES
IN THIS NATION. HE MADE
PATAGONIA THE FIRST UNITED
STATES COMPANY TO GET ITS
ELECTRICITY FROM RENEWABLE
RESOURCES AND ONE OF THE FIRST
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
TRACK AND COMMIT. TO REDUCING
GHG GAS EMISSIONS THAT LED HIM
A FEW YEARS LATER TO WORK WITH
SENATOR BYRON SHARE TO CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION
REGISTRY THE FIRST STATE
REGISTRY OF GREENHOUSE GASES IN
THE NATION. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
MENTION ANOTHER OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT TO ME BOTH IN MY
DISTRICT AND I BELIEVE TO THE
STATE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN HE
PERSONALLY LED THE I SO BORED
TO CHALLENGE INCLUSION OF THE
POINTY GAS GENERATION PROJECT.
IN THE I SO TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TRANSMISSION
PLAN WHICH WOULD HAVE CLEARED
THE WAY FOR THAT PROJECT TO BE
BUILT INSTEAD HE DIRECTED I SO
MANAGEMENT THE STUDY NON FOSSIL
FUEL ALTERNATIVES THE I SO
ANALYSIS SHOWED THE CLEAN
RESOURCES WERE INDEED CAPABLE
OF MEETING THE RELIABILITY NEED
IN THE OXNARD CALIFORNIA AREA.
AN AREA THAT HIS APPROXIMATELY
8290% LATINO EN A DISTRICT THAT
HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT TO AN
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME. AS A RESULT
OF HIS EFFORTS TO S. C. ANY IS
NOW PREPARING THAT RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND AS NOTED IN THE
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM OXNARD.
PRO TEM CARMEN RAMIREZ IT WAS
DAVE'S VISION AND PERSISTENCE
THAT HELP PROTECT THIS
ECONOMICALLY DE A DISADVANTAGE
COASTAL COMMUNITY AND HELP TO
AVOID DECADES MORE OF ADVERSE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. THIS
BECAME A TURNING POINT NOT
SHOWS FOR OXNARD BUT FOR THE
STATE. TO PROCURE CLEAN
RESOURCES INSTEAD OF FOSSIL
FUEL ONCE HE'S BEEN ALSO A
VALUED RESOURCE TO ME ARE BOTH
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY
IN MY INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE.
AND I BELIEVE HE HAS
CONSISTENTLY LED WITH EXPERTISE
A STEADY HAND AND FORWARD
THINKING POLICIES TO BENEFIT
THE STATE AND THE PUBLIC HE HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE EFFORTS. AND I AM
CONFIDENT HE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO AND- HOPE THAT YOU WILL
RECONFIRM HIM TO THIS POSITION
HE IS A REAL TREASURE FOR US.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
DO SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
INTRODUCTION OF THE CHAIRMAN
FOR US IN YOUR SUPPORT WHICH
WILL TAKE UP A LITTLE BIT LATER.
SO LET ME GO AHEAD AND START
AND I. AS TO MISTER OLSON WHO
IS THE CHAIRMAN WILL START WITH
YOU AND LET EACH OF YOU GIVE
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS IT
KNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT CAME WITH
YOU TO SUPPORT YOU IF YOU WANT
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
RULES COMMITTEE. CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MADAM PROTON BUT BEFORE I
BEGIN I'D LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE MY
PARTNER OF FORTY FIVE YEARS
DIANA DO AWAY. ON THE- IN ORDER
THE AUTHOR AS WELL. SO MADAM
PRO TEM. HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID WILSON. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING MY
REAPPOINTMENT TO US SERVE ON
THE GOVERNORS OF THE
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR. IT
IS AN HONOR TO BE ASKED TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TO IMPLEMENT THE DIRECTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE HI AND THE
GOVERNOR IN THIS ROLE.
PERSONALLY AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
WORKED FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS TO MOVE BOTH OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY ON TO A MORE
SOCIALLY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE FOOTING. A HEARING
LIKE THIS IS TREMENDOUSLY
ENCOURAGING IN THAT IT CAN
FOCUS NOW ON CONCRETE STEPS TO
MOVE TO A CLEAN ENERGY SYSTEM.
WITH MY ACTIVE ENCOURAGEMENT
AND SUPPORT. THE I SO HAS
ADOPTED THE AMBITION TO BECOME
THE FIRST GRADE OPERATOR IN THE
WORLD. TO MAKE THE TRANSITION
FROM THE FOSSIL BASED SYSTEM TO
A NON CARBON ONE. WE ARE
ALREADY RECOGNIZED OF WORLD
WIDE AS A LEADER OF FOR THE FOR
OUR WORKING INTEGRATING BOTH
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEMAND
RESOURCES AND STORAGE INTO OUR
DAILY HOURLY AND MINUTE BY
MINUTE OPERATIONS. IN THE PAST
THREE YEARS. GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS IN GRID OPERATORS
FROM MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE
COUNTRIES HAVE VISITED THE ISO
TO LEARN FROM WHAT WE ARE DOING.
OUR C. E. O. STEVE BURKE WAS
RECENTLY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE ORGANIZATION OF THE FIFTEEN
LARGEST GRID OPERATORS
WORLDWIDE. PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
OUR LEADERSHIP IN TRANSLATING
POLICY DIRECTION INTO RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY. LOW
CARBON GRADES HAVE PROFOUNDLY
DIFFERENT CHARACTERISTICS AND
OPERATE IN PROFOUNDLY DIFFERENT
WAYS THAN FOSSEL BASED ONES. AS
WE ELECTRIFY BUILDINGS AND
TRANSPORTATION. POLICY
DEVELOPMENT MUST ENSURE THAT
THE EYES SO HAS THE RESOURCES
AND THE PHYSICAL CAPABILITIES
NEEDED TO SUPPLY ELECTRICITY
WITHOUT RELYING ON FOSSEL
GENERATION. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO DESCEND. HI TO ADVANCE THE
GROUND BREAKING WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEGUN. I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR BORN TODAY.
THANK YOU I WON'T REPEAT
EVERYTHING MISTER OLSON JUST
SAID THOUGH I AGREE WITH ALL OF
IT I AM VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE
AND TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
POTENTIAL POSITION ON THE I SO
BORED I HAVE STUDIED THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY MARKETS FOR
ABOUT THIRTY YEARS FROM
GASOLINE TO ELECTRICITY
INCLUDING THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRICITY CRISIS.
AND HAVE WATCH THOSE MARKETS
EVOLVE AS WE HAVE TURNED TO
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES AND
NOT WHAT IT IS I THINK A VERY
EXCITING WAY. CALIFORNIA IS A
LEADER IN RICH IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES WERE MOVING
VERY QUICKLY TO GREAT MUCH
LOWER LEVELS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES IN OUR ELECTRICITY SYSTEM
AND I THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE'RE CREATING A LOT OF NEW
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS SPREADING TO
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY CALIFORNIA
IS ONLY 1% OF WORLD GREENHOUSE
GASES AND SO THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO. REALLY SOLVE GLOBAL
CLIMATE CHANGE IS BY EXPORTING
THAT KNOWLEDGE IN WAYS THAT
PARTICULARLY THE DEVELOPING
WORLD CAN USE AND TO IN ORDER
TO ADOPT LOW GREENHOUSE GAS
TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO GROW BUT THEY NEED TO GROW
ON A MUCH MORE LOW CARBON PATH
THAN WE HAVE GROUND. SO I A
HAVE WATCH THIS HAPPEN I HAVE
STUDIED AT AND I HAVE ADVISED
ON IT OCCASIONALLY BUT I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF ACTUALLY PARTICIPATING AS A
BOARD MEMBER. I THINK THE CHI
SO IS ONE OF IS PROBABLY THE
MOST INNOVATIVE AND EXCITING
PART OF THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. IN PART
OUT OF NECESSITY THEY HAVE HAD
TO. INNOVATE AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE THIS SYSTEM WORK WITH
HIGHER AND HIGHER LEVELS OF
RENEWABLES. THEY'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB DAY AS MISTER OLSON
SAID HAVE OUR CONSTANTLY
VISITED BY OTHER COUNTRIES AND
STATES TO LOOK AT HOW WE'RE
DOING IT. AND I THINK BEING
PART OF THAT IS A IS VERY
EXCITING FOR ME. I ALSO THINK I
BRING SOME EXPERTISE
PARTICULARLY ON THE ENERGY
MARKETS SIDE THAT CAN BE USEFUL
AS WE CONTINUE TO RAMP UP
RENEWABLES. AND I THINK THE
NEXT TEN YEARS WILL BE A VERY
EXCITING TIME TO BE PART OF THE
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS LESSON.
THANK YOU AND I'M SURE YOUR
ENTHUSIASM BOTH MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE FOR THIS JOB GOOD
AFTERNOON ON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE BEING HERE TODAY
SEEKING YOUR SUPPORT I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOWLEDGE MY FAMILY WHO
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT PHYSICALLY
HERE TODAY HOWEVER ON.
HOPEFULLY ARE LISTENING MY SON
JACOB IS BACK IN BOSTON I JUST
DROPPED HIM FOR HIS FIRST YEAR
LAW SCHOOL AND MY SON MICHAEL
IS AT U. S. C. FINISHING HIS
SENIOR YEAR IN INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS MY HUSBAND WHO DID
OFFER TO BE. WHAT IS A
PROFESSOR AT USC THE SCHOOL
YEAR HAS JUST BEGUN HE HAS A
CHAIR IN THE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AT USC AND ON I WANT
TO THANK THE BUSINESS TEAM I
RUN A ORGANIZATION LOS ANGELES
CALLED THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND IF THEY'RE
LISTENING I WANT TO THANK THEM
BECAUSE THEY SHARE MY PASSION
FOR SUSTAINABILITY. AND ON HAVE
BEEN A BIG PART OF SUPPORTING
THIS EFFORT THIS YEAR I WAS
HONORED TO BE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN JANUARY TO
THE I. SO BORED AND I SEE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY TO BE CONFIRMED
FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
CURRENTLY SEVEN FROM PARALLEL
UNIVERSES I HAVE COMMITTED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CLIMATE
ISSUES I BEGAN MY CAREER HERE.
ON AS WITH THE FORMER SPEAKER
LITTLE MCCARTHY FORTUNATELY
SOME OF YOU ACTUALLY REMEMBER
LABEL CARTHY I RAN THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION FOR THE
CITY CALIFORNIA AND ON I EVEN
THEN WE WERE LOOKING AT HOW
REGULATION COULD CREATE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND I
THINK THAT A LOT WHILE
SAFEGUARDING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES IN I THINK IS WHAT
MAKES THE STATE'S SPECIAL. AS
WHAT ARE WE APPROVING THAT WE
CAN DO I HAVE ALSO SERVED IN
STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON AND I HAVE BEEN
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER BOARD OF COMMISSIONERS
FOR MANY YEARS AND ON AS YOU
KNOW THAT THAT HAS THE
DISTINCTION OF BEING ONE OF THE
LARGEST. MUNICIPAL UTILITIES IN
THE UNITED STATES AT AT AT THE.
TIME ONE OF THE DIRTIEST SO I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART
OF A TRANSITION FROM COLD TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY. IT'S A TOUGH
TRANSITION BUT IT'S SO WORTH
WHILE ONE. I'M ALSO PART OF
THEIR INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING AND ALSO THE 100%
RENEWABLE ON ADVISORY GROUP. I
WAS ALSO PART OF OUR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ARE IN POWER IN THE
LA B. C. WE HELP CREATE ONE OF
THE LARGEST SOLAR ROOF TOP
PROGRAMS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND ON WE HELP DO THE RESEARCH
POLICY DESIGN AND- EVALUATION
OF THE PROGRAM SO I'VE I HAVE
BUILT A PROGRAM ON THE GROUND.
IN THE RENEWABLE WORLD I'M
EXCITED TO SERVE ON THE
CALIFORNIA I SO BORED. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT JOB AS WE
TRANSITION TO A LOW CARBON GRID
I THINK OUR JOB IS TO MAINTAIN
RELIABILITY WHILE
TRANSITIONING. OF TO OUR
CLIMATE GOALS WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE A GOOD JOB
CREATING. ALL ON I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE WILL ACHIEVE
OUR GOALS AND THAT THIS IS A
PROCESS THAT WILL REQUIRE FULL
COOPERATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. AND I THINK WE HAVE A
VERY IMPRESSIVE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED TEAM OF THE EYES SO.
AND WE'RE LUCKY TO HAVE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I SENATOR RALPH WOULD YOU LIKE
TO START US OFF. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM WELL
FIRST CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL
THREE OF YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO. SERVER CONTINUE
TO SERVE US A VERY VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FUNCTION THAT YOU.
PROVIDE FOR ALL OF US
PARTICULAR THOSE OF US WHO ARE
NOT QUITE AS KNOWLEDGEABLE. IN
THIS AREA IS I'M SURE YOU ARE.
OF DURING THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION AND PERHAPS
IT'LL COME UP AGAIN FOR US WE
SPENT SOME TIME. LISTENING TO
CONVERSATION ABOUT
pWONDERING FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON
REGIONALIZATION WHAT THE
ADVANTAGES FOR THE STATE WOULD
BE AND IN PARTICULAR WHAT THE
POTENTIAL PITFALLS. FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A WOULD BE
SHOULD WE MOVE DOWN THIS ROAD
HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION AND.
TAKE OTHER ACTION THAT MAY GET
US THERE FOR QUESTION.
PROFESSOR I WILL START I DON'T
I'M NOT TOO. CALIFORNIA IS
MOVING TOWARD VERY HIGH LEVELS
OF INTERMITTENT RENEWABLES AND
IN ORDER TO MAKE THE GREAT
BALANCE WE'RE GOING TO NEED
SOME FORM BUT SOME ABILITY TO
SMOOTH THE SYSTEM THAT CAN BE
STORAGE THAT CAN BE NATURAL GAS
AND TO SOME EXTENT THAT CAN
ALSO BE TRADE WITH OTHER PARTS
OF THE WEST OF CAL AT THE WE
HAVE BEEN TRADING WITH OTHER
PARTS OF THE WEST FOR YEARS KID
THE I SO IN FIVE YEARS AGO
STARTED AN IMBALANCE MARKET
WHICH IS SMALL STAFF. SOME
TRADING IN THE VERY SHORT TERM
MARKET THAT SEEMS TO BE WORKING
WELL THE CONCERNS ABOUT
DOWNSIDES PARTICULARLY ABOUT
BOLSTERING COAL IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE WEST OR LOSS OF CONTROL
OF OUR SYSTEM DON'T SEEM TO BE
REALLY BEARING OUT BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT WE NEED TO RIGHT NOW
SAY WE'RE GOING TO GO ALL THE
WAY TO FULL REGIONALIZATION THE
NEXT STEP WHICH DIET SO HAS
BEGUN TO EXPLORE ALWAYS WITH
WORKING GROUP'S WITH A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT ISN'T
IT IT'S A DAY AHEAD MARKET THIS
WOULD BE A MUCH BIGGER MARKET.
THAN THE IMBALANCE MARKET I
THINK THE SIGNS ARE GOOD THAT
THAT WAY IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WILL PURSUE ONCE WE DO THAT
WE'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO THEN
EVALUATE THAT AND SEE HOW IT
YOU SEE HOW THAT'S GOING SO I
CS MOVING TOWARDS
REGIONALIZATION BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY NEED TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO DO FULL
REGIONALIZATION AT THIS POINT I
THINK THAT WE WILL LEARN AS WE
GO. ON UP I EXPECT THAT WE'LL
LEARN MOSTLY POSITIVE THINGS
BUT WE WILL HAVE TIME TO
OBSERVE AND SEE IF SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS ARE BORN OUT A
SO FAR THEY HAVEN'T BEEN BUT I
BELIEVE. IN FOLLOWING DATA AND
SO WE'LL SEE LEARN MORE AS. WE
GO. ANYONE ELSE EVEN IF I A. R.
CAN ADD TO THAT AND TALK A
LITTLE BIT. SO SOON HOUSE
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
REQUIRED THE I SO TO DO A
SERIES OF STUDIES OF THE
BENEFITS. OF REGIONALIZATION OF
REGIONAL INTEGRATION
INTEGRATING THE THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT BALANCING AREAS IN
THE WEST. DAD STUDIES THOSE
STUDIES WERE DONE BY
INDEPENDENT CONSULTANTS FOUND A
VERY LARGE SAVINGS MORE THAN
ONE BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR TO
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS. FROM
BEING ABLE TO OPERATE
REGIONALLY INSTEAD OF STATE BY
STATE OF ONE OF THE BENEFITS IS
THE. MANY POWER PLANTS IN OTHER
STATES IN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
STATES COULD BE RETIRED
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE ALL RIGHT
NOW HE EVERY BALANCING AREA HAS
TO MAINTAIN RESERVES IN ITS OWN
SO WE HAVE THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT HAVE TO.
BE OPERATING POWER PLANTS WHICH
ARE NOT NEEDED TO MEET THE
NEEDS THE LOAD EVERY DAY SO.
ACTUALLY DOZENS OF THOSE PLANS
COULD BE IMMEDIATELY RETIRED.
THAT'S ONE SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT
ADEN BUT FOR CALIFORNIA BEING
ABLE TO HAVE READY LOW COST
ACCESS TO A MUCH LARGER POOL OF
CLEAN RESOURCES. MRS THE
FASTEST AND LEASE COST WAY TO
MEET OUR GREENHOUSE GAS SCHOOLS
THE DONE THAT WAS ONE OF THE
KEY. HE AIMS HERE. THE NEED FOR
RESOURCE DIVERSITY I'D I REALLY
THINK NEEDS TO BE EMPHASIZED SO
RIGHT NOW MOST OF OUR LARGE
SCALE SOLAR PROJECTS ARE IN THE
SOUTHERN PART OF THE STATE.
WHEN WE HAVE MONSOONAL FLOWS
WERE PERIODS OF STORMS WE LOSE
AT THE EYES SO WE WE'VE LOST UP
290% OF OUR SOLAR OUTPUT. FROM
OUR OUR DAY TO DAY. SO WE HAVE
NOW ALMOST TWELVE THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF LARGE SCALE SOLAR
PROJECTS. WE HAVE ON SOME DAYS
THIS YEAR AND AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR WONDER WAS STORMY
WEATHER WE WERE ONLY GETTING
ONE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS INSTEAD
OF TWELVE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS.
DAD ARE IS NOT A PROBLEM FOR US
SO MUCH TODAY BECAUSE WE CAN
ORDER GAS GENERATION TO WRAP UP
TO MEET THAT NEED. BUT IF GAS
IS GOING TO RUN LESS. AND WE
RELY LESS AND LESS ON GAS
GENERATION. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO SOLAR
RESOURCES IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
WEST WHICH HAVE DIFFERENT
WEATHER PATTERNS. SO IF THIRDS
STORMS IN CALIFORNIA BEING ABLE
TO GET SOLAR FROM NEW MEXICO OR
UTAH. OF OR THE EASTERN OREGON.
HE IS GOING TO BECOME MORE AND
MORE IMPORTANT. THE VERY
SIMILAR STORY WITH WIND WITH ON
SHORE WIND DURING PERIODS OF
HIGH PRESSURE HEAT WAVES WHICH
CONSIDER OVER THE STATE FOR A
WEEK OR MORE AT A TIME. THERE
IS NO WIND BECAUSE OF HIGH
PRESSURE EVENTS. SO AGAIN
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM FOR US NOW
SO MUCH BECAUSE WE CAN TURN TO
GAS GENERATION. BUT IF WE MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF SB ONE
HUNDRED WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
LESS AND LESS ABILITY TO TURN
THE GAS FIRED GENERATION SO
THAT REALLY UNDERLINES THE NEED
FOR US TO THINK REGIONALLY.
THERE'S ONE OTHER IMPORTANT
THING THAT BEARS MENTIONING.
HERE ARE HAN. IN SB THREE FIFTY
WHICH WAS ONLY THREE YEARS AGO.
THE ENERGY LANDSCAPE IN THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA WAS THE ONLY
STATE TO HAVE A 50% RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOAL. NOW THERE ARE SIX
STATES THAT HAVE 1100%
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS AND A
SEVENTH IDAHO THE STATE HAS
MADE A COMMITMENT BUT THE
UTILITY IDAHO POWER HAS MADE A
COMMITMENT TO. TURN TRANSITION
TO A 100% OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
SO THAT HAS DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE BUT WHAT
THAT MEANS ALSO IS THAT NOW WE
HAVE MANY OTHER STATES THAT ARE
THAT WILL BE DEVELOPING A WHOLE
LOT MORE WIND AND SOLAR
RESOURCES. SINCE WE ALL WANT TO
MOVE TO A LOW CARBON ECONOMY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SHARE
OUR RESOURCES AND THAT HE IS
THE FUNDAMENTAL IDEA BEHIND
INTEGRATING ALL THESE REGIONAL
BOUNCING AREAS TO MAKE IT EASY
LOW COST WAY. TO SHARE YOUR
WIND AND SOLAR RESOURCES HYDRO
GEOTHERMAL ACROSS THE STATE
MINES. IS LESLIE ANY FURTHER
COMMENT. I WOULD JUST SAY ON
THAT I THINK IT'S A TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX IN THE THAT THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT REALLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
CLIMATE GOALS WE SET THE GOAL
OF 60% RENEWABLE ENERGY
APPROACHING US IN TWENTY THIRTY
WE SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATED 33%
ON TO THE GRID. SO THE ISSUE IS
HOW DO WE GO FROM THE THIRTY
THREE TO THE SIXTY WE DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE A PLAN IN MIND WHEN
WE ADOPTED THOSE GOALS FOR NOW
WORKING ON THE PLAN SO THAT'S
WHY I THINK YOU SEE THE SERIES
OF OPTIONS BEING PRESENTED
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO RULE
ANYTHING OUT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE A GOAL YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE BUT TO THAT POINT. I
THINK THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IT HAS A LOT OF
CONTROL OVER AND THAT HELP
MITIGATE THE BELLY OF THE DUCK
TO MAKE THE NEXT YOU KNOW NOT
IN A STRANGLED SITUATION AND
THAT IS THAT LIKE TO ME AND
RESPONSE TIME OF DAY YOU USE
THESE ARE ALL WITHIN YOUR
CONTROL. THE. THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THESE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT MITIGATE THE
BILL IS THE DEATH. OF THESE ARE
WITHIN YOUR CONTROL SO TO THAT.
END I THINK THIS IS A
COLLABORATION THERE WERE IN
THIS IS A- THIS IS A- A SHARED
GOAL OF GETTING TO THE 60% GOAL
AND A 100% OVER TWENTY FORTY
FIVE SO. I WOULD I WOULD I
WOULD HAVE YOU CONSIDER THOSE
AS WELL. VERY VERY INFORMATIVE
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS AND OTHER RELATED
ISSUES. CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN I
HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS LOOK
FORWARD TO MOVING YOUR-
NOMINATIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK
YOU SENATOR ROTH MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. ARE CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR POLL REAPPOINTMENT AN
APPOINTMENT. I REALLY
APPRECIATED WHAT YOU SHARED
ABOUT WE ONLY A MINUTE 1% OF
ALL CARBON AND WHAT OUR ROLE IS.
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING IS
EXPLORING TECHNOLOGIES AND BEST
PRACTICES SO EVERYBODY ELSE CAN
JOIN IS SO APPRECIATED HEARING
THAT. MY MAIN QUESTION WAS THE
ONE I WAS ASKED WE SAT AROUND I
COULD ASK YOU GUYS A QUESTION
JUST AS YOUR QUESTION I'M NOT
GONNA DO THAT I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH ALL OF YOU
YESTERDAY. THINK THESE ARE
EXCELLENT SELECTIONS AT THE
GOVERNOR MADE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING THAT
THIS A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS
BECAUSE IT'S GONNA TAKE OFFICE
WORKING TOGETHER TO GET THERE
SO WITH THAT CONGRATULATIONS I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I TO
WANT TO ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS
AND PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY
OUR APPRECIATION FOR YEAR
STEPPING UP MISTER OLSON FOR
YOUR CONTINUATION AND FOR THE
TWO OF YOU STEPPING UP TO. HELP
LEADERS IN THESE. ACHIEVING OUR
TARGETS WHILE PROTECTING.
CALIFORNIANS SIN. REDUCING OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT I'LL START
WITH THE QUESTION TO MISTER
OLSON. YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF EXPANDING OUR
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO REDUCING
OUR RELIANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS IS
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT PART OF MY
DISTRICT TO SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY WHERE WE'RE DE
COMMISSIONING. DIABLO CANYON
WHICH CURRENTLY PRODUCES ABOUT
10% OF P. GENIES ENERGY AND
ABOUT 5% OF THE STATE WIDE GRID.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS
EXPLORATION WELL UNDER WAY FOR
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY MAY BE
USING SOME OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. JUST CURIOUS
YOUR THOUGHTS ON. THE ROLE THAT
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY MIGHT PLAY
THE OPPORTUNITIES THE OBSTACLES.
THANK YOU SENATOR BIDEN I THINK
OUR OFFSHORE WIND HE HAS A VERY
LARGE AND IMPORTANT ROLE TO
PLAY IN MEETING OUR CLEAN
ENERGY NEEDS. IT'S A TREMENDOUS
RESOURCE. IT IS VERY DIFFERENT
VIDEO LOGICALLY DOWN THE ON
SHORE WIND RESOURCE WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. OF MUCH MORE
POWERFUL WINDS THAT BLOW MANY
MORE HOURS OF THE YEAR ARE
GENERALLY NOT AFFECTED BY THE
HIGH PRESSURE HEAT WAVE EVENTS
THAT WE HAVE OVER LAND. ADEN SO
IT'S A RELATIVELY CLOSE BY AND
AS YOU POINT OUT BECAUSE IT IS
CAPABLE OF UTILIZING DE
INTERCONNECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THE SUBSTATIONS AND THE
TRANSMISSION LINES THAT DYEABLE
CANYON POWER PLANT HAS USE. SO
THERE'S A POTENTIAL TO GREATLY
REDUCE THE COST OF OFFSHORE
WIND BY UTILIZING THAT ALREADY
BUILT INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
CLINTON THERE'S THERE WOULD BE
I THINK OF VERY STRONG CASE FOR
USING OUR BEST EFFORTS AS A
STATE TO HAVE THIS RESOURCE.
DEVELOPED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THE ARE ON THE OBSTACLES RIGHT
NOW CAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE IS CONCERNED ABOUT
POTENTIAL INTERFERENCE THAT
OFFSHORE WIND TOWERS COULD POSE
TO THEIR OPERATIONS OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. ON THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
HAS TAKEN THE LEAD IN
NEGOTIATING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE SO OF THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION DAVID
HAWKSHAW OLD AND COMMISSIONER
KAREN DOUGLAS AVENUE LEADING
DETAILED DISCUSSIONS. AND I
THINK THEY'RE APPROACHING THIS
IN A VERY PROACTIVE WAY YEAH
AND. HI I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT WE
WILL OF THE GET SOME AGREEMENT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
THAT WILL ALLOW. SOME
DEVELOPMENT IN SOME OFF SHORE
AREAS WE DON'T KNOW WHICH ONES
YET. SO THAT'S THE FIRST UP THE
SECOND STEP IS THEN THE BUREAU
OF OCEAN ENERGY MANAGEMENT WILL
HAVE TO ISSUE LEASES. AND THEN
THERE CAN BE COMPETITIVE
BIDDING OF BY THE WIND
COMPANIES TO ACTUALLY DEVELOP
THOSE LEASES WHEN WE GET TO
THAT POINT THE I. S. O. WOULD
THEN GET INVOLVED OF BECAUSE
THOSE OFFSHORE WIND PROJECTS
WILL NEED TO CONNECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA GRIT. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN HELP
FACILITATE AT THAT POINT. WE
HAVE ALREADY DONE SOME
PRELIMINARY STUDIES THAT WOULD
LOOK AT POTENTIAL FOWS OF
POWER FROM OFFSHORE WIND USING
THE DIAL BELOW CANYON
INFRASTRUCTURE. OF WE WILL DO
MORE DETAILS STUDIES AS THIS
PROGRESSES BUT I THINK FROM ALL
IN ALL RESOURCE POINT OF VIEW.
THIS IS A VERY VERY POSITIVE
AND PROMISING RESOURCE FOR US
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- I
WAS ENCOURAGED WHEN WE SPOKE
YESTERDAY BY YEAR. WITH YOUR
KNOWLEDGE AND YOUR ENTHUSIASM I
KNOW IT SHARED BY. MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WE'VE BEEN IN
REGULAR CONTACT WITH KAREN
DOUGLAS AND MR HAVE CHILD. END
I KNOW THERE. ME INVOLVED IN
THIS NEGOTIATIONS WITH
DEPARTMENT OFFENSE YOU ALSO
CITED ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSIDERATIONS. MARINE MARINE
LIFE CONSIDERATIONS BUT WE'RE
NOT THE FIRST TO EMBARK ON THIS
IN IN THE NORTH ATLANTIC
THERE'S WIND ENERGY THAT'S I
THINK SERVING NORTHERN EUROPE
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN VERY LARGE
AMOUNT. YES SO AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN IN ALL OF
THE BOARD AS AS THIS PART OF
OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY FORWARD.
ENERGY FUTURE MIGHT MOVE
FORWARD IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I WILL MOVE TO DR. BORENSTEIN
WITH A WITH A DIFFERENT
QUESTION WE SPOKE SOME
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE- COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION THE CCA'S
THAT ARE SETTING UP REGIONAL
BUYING GROUPS FOR LACK OF A
BETTER DESCRIPTION I'M JUST
CURIOUS YOUR THOUGHTS ON. HOW
HOW DO THEY FIT IN TO OUR
ENERGY FUTURE AND THE ROLE OF
THE BIG ENERGY PRODUCERS VERSUS
THESE MORE COMMUNITY BASED TO
REGIONAL BASED. AT LEAST IN
BUYING UNITS YEAH I THINK THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I THINK WE
NEED TO BE CLEAR ON WHAT CCA'S
DO THEY ARE. IN SOME WAYS A
LATTER DAY VERSION OF RETAIL
CHOICE WHICH WE HAD BACK IN THE
NINETIES AND RESTRUCTURING I
DON'T WANT TO TAR IT IN ANY WAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRICITY
CRISIS. WHICH WAS NOT CAUSED BY
THAT BUT BUT I THINK IT IS. AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT PEOPLE ARE
OFFERED FOR HOW THEY CAN
CONTRACT FOR THEIR ELECTRICITY.
NOT THAT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE DOING ANYTHING PHYSICALLY
TO CARRY ELECTRICITY OR
GENERATE ELECTRICITY THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT A CITY CAN
SAY WILL BE OUR PRIMARY OR
DEFAULT. ELECTRICITY PROVIDER.
AS SUCH I THINK IT WOULD THEY
OFFERED EXCITING ALTERNATIVES.
THEY HAVE GIVEN CITIES THE
POSSIBILITY OF. DECIDING TO BUY
HIGHER LEVELS OF RENEWABLES.
AND DIETING TO BUY MORE LOCAL
ENERGY GENERATION IF THEY WANT
TO. THERE ARE ALWAYS CONCERNS
WHEN WE HAVE MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS DOING WITH
OVERLAPPING RESPONSIBILITIES
AND SO WHEN WE HAVE CCA'S OR
RETAIL CHOICE. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE CLEAR WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS FOR
INSTANCE TO ACQUIRE RESERVES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CUSTOMERS
ARE WELL INFORMED ABOUT THEIR
ALTERNATIVES AND SO FORTH. I
THINK AND HOW COSTS ARE GONNA
BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS RETAIL PROVIDERS I
THINK WE HAD SOME BUMPING THIS
AT THE BEGINNING AROUND THOSE
ISSUES DATES GETTING SORTED
OUT. MY VIEW AND I HAVE WORKED
WITH A COUPLE OF THE CCA'S TO
THINK ABOUT ALTERNATIVE RETAIL
RATE STRUCTURES. THAT THEY HAVE
THE POTENTIAL FOR IMPLEMENTING
IN WAYS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
MUCH MORE FAST AND EXPERIMENTAL
THEN YOU'D THEN THE BIG
UTILITIES COULD DO GOING TO THE
CPSC. SO IN THAT WAY I THINK
BACK TO THE IDEA OF KNOWLEDGE
CREATION OF HAVING THE SORT OF
BASTIONS OF EXPERIMENTATION
WHERE THEY CAN TRY NEW THINGS
WHETHER IT'S VERY HIGH
RENEWABLES. DIFFERENT RETAIL
RATE STRUCTURE FOR GIVES US
MORE POSSIBILITIES AND I THINK
HAVE AND I THINK THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE THERE AT THE
BEGINNING ARE GRADUALLY BEING
WORKED OUT IN TERMS OF.
ALLOCATE RESPONSIBILITIES
BETWEEN THE UTILITIES AND THESE
RETAIL PROVIDERS BECAUSE THE
UTILITIES. ARE STILL IN THE
POWER PROVIDING STRIP. AT WORK
AND SO FORTH SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR ON WHAT
WHICH ORGANIZATION HAS EACH
RESPONSIBILITY THANK YOU IN IN
JUST A TALE ON TO THAT. SO THE
CCA'S AS YOU INDICATED THEY'RE
NOT PRODUCING THE ENERGY
THEY'RE NOT CREATING IT THEIR
MARKETING AND MOVE BUT THEY'RE
RELYING ON THE BIG UTILITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MOVE IT. CAN
THE BIG UTILITIES. SURVIVE
PROVIDING ONLY THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IF THEY'RE NOT.
AT THE SAME TIME MARKETING THE
ENERGY IF I'M FRAMING THAT
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY I A I THINK
THAT THAT IT THERE IS CLEARLY
THE POSSIBILITY OF HAVING
UTILITIES THAT OUR WIRES
COMPANIES. AND THAT I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT'S WHERE WE
SHOULD GO BUT THERE ARE
EXAMPLES OF THAT AROUND THE
WORLD AND IN A IN WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES AND THAT IS ONE
POSSIBLE MODEL AND SO I THINK
THAT IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT WILL REMAIN ON THE TABLE
IS A POSSIBILITY. AND
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO EXPLORE THAT JUST AS WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
COMMUNITY RETAILING CCA'S AND
PROBLEMS AND WE STILL HAVE
CUSTOMERS WHO WERE ON DIRECT
ACCESS OR RETAIL CHOICE THROUGH
PRIVATE COMPANIES AND I THINK
THAT. WE COULD END UP WITH THE
MODEL AND IT'S A PERFECTLY
WORKABLE MODEL WHERE THE WIRES
COMPANY THE DISTRIBUTION
COMPANY DOES DOESN'T PROCURE
ELECTRICITY FOR ANYBODY THEY
JUST MAKE THEIR MONEY ON THE
WIRE SIDE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN LAST BUT NOT LEAST MISS
LESLIE WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A
LITTLE BIT YESTERDAY TOO AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY. YOU BRING
SUCH A VAST EXPERIENCE FROM
STATE GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
IN YOUR INVOLVEMENT WITH. WHEN
OF WATER AND POWER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND SINCE YOU COME.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM
THE POLITICAL WORLD THEN YOUR
COLLEAGUES WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
REGIONALIZATION. IT SEEMS LIKE
FROM AN ECONOMIC POINT OF VIEW
THERE ARE GREAT SAVINGS AND
EFFICIENCIES TO BE GAINED I
THINK SOME OF THE CONCERN
WITHIN OUR LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
EXERCISE OF POLITICAL POWER IN
GOVERNANCE IF CALIFORNIA
BECOMES PART OF A LARGER
REGIONAL SYSTEM ANY THOUGHTS
ON. COMMITTING GOVERNANCE
QUESTION OF HOW CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T OF SACRIFICE ITS ITS
ABILITY TO CONTROL OUR OWN
ENERGY FUTURE. I DON'T HAVE A
SOLUTION BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THE FEAR ON. MAINLY BECAUSE
LOOK AT THE VALUE OF THE ICE
THE ICE IS BEEN INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE TO CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
I DIDN'T REALLY APPRECIATE IT
UNTIL I GOT I WAS PART OF THIS
PROCESS TO SELF CRITICAL THE
ICE WHO IS ON AYE WE DEALT
QUITE A BIT WITH FOR THE
DEPARTMENT MODERN POWER BECAUSE
OF COURSE WERE REGULATED BY THE
AND THEN WE'RE PERMITTED BY
THEM SO I'M FAMILIAR WITH THEM.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO SEE
WHAT WE NEED AS THIS OF ALL
RIGHT I THINK THE E. I AM THIS
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET EVEN
FROM THE DWP PERSPECTIVE IS A
TERRIFIC OPPORTUNITY THE
DELIVERY PEOPLE AND THAT I
THINK IN TWO YEARS. I THINK
WITH THE BOARD CREATED WHAT
WOULD SPLIT DAVE AND OTHERS
CREATED IS REALLY GOING TO HELL
CALIFORNIA HOW BROADER
RELATIONSHIPS AND BRING OTHER
ENERGY AND OTHER BALANCING
AUTHORITIES INTO ONE SYSTEM AND
THAT WILL HELP US GET TO THE
STATE GOALS BECAUSE THERE IS
SILOS EVEN WITH IN CALIFORNIA
THE E. I AM THIS IS SOLVING
THAT IS PART OF SOLVING THAT SO
I THINK AS- DOCTOR BORN SEEN
SAID THIS IS AN ERROR TO
PROCESS RIGHT LET'S SEE HOW THE
I AM BECAUSE WE HAVE EIGHT NINE
MEMBERS NOW. WE'RE GONNA PICK
UP EIGHT OR NINE MORE IN TWO
YEARS WE'LL HAVE WE'LL HAVE A
PRETTY GOOD FEEL FOR A BROAD
BASED GROUP THIS IS THE REAL
TIME MARKET WE'RE TRADING IN 5%
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
EVOLVING INTO THE EDM WHICH IS
THE ON THE DAY AHEAD MARKET
THAT WOULD MEAN WE'D BE LOOKING.
AT A 100% MARKET OF ENERGY
TRADING. YOU KNOW AT THAT POINT
I DON'T WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE RESPONSE WILL BE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO THAT BUT
WE THINK IT COULD BE POSITIVE.
ON WILL HAVE A GOOD IDEA OF
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE TO US.
RIGHT WING WILL KNOW YOU KNOW
IF WE SAVE SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TODAY. AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION OF THAT HAS
BEEN TO CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW
YOU CAN JUST THINKING AHEAD
BECAUSE ONE THING WE DON'T KNOW
IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COST
OF A 100% RENEWABLE. IT LOOKS
LIKE YEAH RIGHT RIGHT WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT AGAIN YEAR.
DISPLAY OF KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE-
WE'RE BUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ALREADY. AND I
THINK IN POLITICS OFTEN IT'S
BUILDING THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO TAKE THAT
LEAP. FORWARD TO INTERESTING.
BROADER RESPONSIBILITY TO A
BROADER GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO.
WHO IN THE END SHARE COMMON
OBJECTIVES BUT. I'M SURE I
WANNA YOU'VE BEEN INDULGING
LETTER IT THIS IS R. ENERGY
FUTURES SO CRITICAL. IN THE
POSITIONS THAT YOU ARE BEING.
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
FULFILL THERE'S SO MUCH MORE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT. OUR ROLE IN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND
MODELING. AS WAS INDICATED IN
THE OPENING STATEMENT SO AGAIN
MY THANKS ALL OF YOU IN AND
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SURE. I THANK YOU SENATOR
I THINK THIS IS. STRUCTURE TO
UNDERSTAND SO I APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES BRING UP THE ISSUE
OF. REGIONALIZATION AND
GOVERNANCE THAT SEEMS TO BE
WERE WE GET STUCK WHILE YOU'RE
BUSY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AN
EVEN BIGGER MORE COMPLEX.
OVERALL HOW WE FIT INTO THIS
AND WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE IN
WATER THE EFFICIENCIES OF SCALE
BY BROADENING. BUT IT AND IN
THIS MAY BE A SIMPLE QUESTION I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO
MISTER OLSON YESTERDAY I DIDN'T
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITY WITH
YOU SO TO THIS TO YOU. I WOULD
ASK YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THE
STATE'S ABILITY WE ALREADY HAVE
AUTHORIZATION UNDER LAW TO DO
BILATERAL TRANSACTIONS TO BUY
AND SELL RENEWABLES. HI SO
REGIONALIZATION IS BIGGER THAN
THAT GOVERNANCE IS BIGGER THAN
THAT BUT IF WE ALREADY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO MUCH OF WHAT WE
NEED TO DO WHY THE PUSH FOR
REGIONALIZATION FROM AYE AYE IS
SO I IN THE PAST YOU HAVE A
PREVIOUS GOVERNOR WHO SUPPORTED
REGIONALIZATION YOU HAVE A
CURRENT GOVERNOR WHO IS DUBIOUS
OF IT AT LEAST AT ONE POINT
WHEN HE AND I SPOKE. BEFORE HE
WAS SWORN IN SO FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE I HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO MISTER OLSEN I'D BE
APPRECIATIVE TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT EVEN IF I YOU
MAY HAVE ALREADY COVERED A LOT
OF IT BUT I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF WE CAN CURRENTLY
DO I WHAT IT IS THE INTENT. WHY
PUSH. FIRST GIVE UP OUR THIRTY.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS THE IMBALANCE MARKET WHICH
IS ONLY 5% IS MISS LESLEE SAID
WHAT WERE MOVING TOWARDS IS THE
DAY HAD MARKET WHICH IS WHERE
ESSENTIALLY THE REST OF THE
POWER ULTIMATELY IS TRANSACTED
OKAY BUT THE BUT THE
DISTINCTION LET ME AND I'M
SORRY LET ME I'M TRYING TO
FOLLOW. THAT'S THE DISTINCTION
NO NO THAT'S THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE IMBALANCE MARKET IN
THE DAY I HAD BOTH OF THOSE CAN
BE DONE WITHOUT A REGIONAL
SYSTEM OPERATOR WHAT CANNOT BE
DONE WITHOUT A REGIONAL SYSTEM
OPERATOR IS TRANSMISSION
PLANNING INTEGRATED
TRANSMISSION PLANNING SO IF YOU
REALLY GOING TO HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT IS DISPATCHED EFFICIENTLY
YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO PLAN THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM FOR INSTANCE TO
MAKE SURE THERE'S ENOUGH
TRANSMISSION CAPACITY. TO MOVE
THE SOLAR POWER IN THE EARLY
AFTERNOON WHEN THE SUN IS
SETTING IN NEW MEXICO INTO
CALIFORNIA ARE THE OTHER WAY
AROUND FROM CALIFORNIA TO
MEXICO AND IN THE MORNING WHEN
THE SUN IS COMING UP IN NEW
MEXICO INTO CALIFORNIA SO
HAVING THAT SORT OF
TRANSMISSION PLANNING ALLOWS US
TO NOT JUST DISPATCHED DAY TO
DAY MORE EFFICIENTLY BUT TO
ACTUALLY BUILD AN ENTIRE SYSTEM
THAT'S INTEGRATED THAT ALLOWS
US TO. LOWER THE COST OF
INTEGRATING THESE INTERMITTENT
RENEWABLES SO I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GET A LOT FROM THE DAY
HAD MARKET I THINK WHAT WE'VE
GOTTEN SO FAR FROM JUST THE
IMBALANCE MARKET IS A VERY TINY
PIECE BUT ULTIMATELY IF WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO HAVE AN
EFFICIENT OPERATION WHERE WE
USE A VERY VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
INTERMITTENT RESOURCES THERE
ARE GOING TO BE BIG ADVANTAGES
TO REGIONALIZATION. NOW THERE
ARE POTENTIAL CONCERNS TO AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE CONSTANTLY
MONITORING THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BENEFITS ARE LARGE
ENOUGH TO JUSTIFY ANY CONCERNS.
AND YOUR CONCERNS WOULD BE WELL
ONE OF THE CONCERNS HAS. AND
THAT THIS IS GOING TO KEEP COAL
PLANTS OPERATING LONGER AND I
THINK THE EVIDENCE SO FAR
DOESN'T SUPPORT THAT BUT IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT. AND THERE ARE
LEGAL CONCERNS ALTHOUGH I WILL
CONFESS I AM NOT AN EXPERT AT
THAT. THANK YOU AND MISTER
OLSON SHARED THAT. ANYTHING YOU
WANT TO ADD I WAS GONNA SAY I
DON'T THINK REGIONALIZATION
UNTO ITSELF IS THE GOAL YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S WHAT I SAID
BEFORE I THINK IT'S A TOOL YOU
KNOW I THINK THE- I THINK WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO FAR MAKES SENSE
WE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
INCORPORATE 33% RENEWABLES ONTO
THE GRID. SO FAR. I THINK IT
WAS WISE TO PLAN FOR ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO APPROACH THIS WITH THE
I AM I THINK THE I AM GOING TO
PROVE VERY BENEFICIAL. AS SEVEN
JUST SAID YOU YOU CAN ADD THE
EDM WITHOUT CHANGING ANY OF THE
ON. THE STRUCTURE OR THE
AUTHORITY OF THE KING OF THE
CALIFORNIA ON THE GOVERNANCE
ISSUE I DON'T REALLY THINK WE
NEED TO DO MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
AT THIS POINT I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS YOU MIGHT
CONSIDER DOING A DEMAND
RESPONSE. YOU KNOW SOME OF
THESE OTHER THINGS WITHIN OUR
CONTROL BECAUSE WHY ARE WE
DOING THIS AT ALL WE'RE TRYING
TO MITIGATE. THE PEAK THE PEAK
ON A TIMES ON THE ON THE GRID
WE WANT TO MAINTAIN GRID
RELIABILITY THE THING THAT
THREATENS GRID RELIABILITY IS
THAT STEEP RAMP THIS HAPPENING
BETWEEN. FIVE AND NINE SO
THAT'S. WHAT THAT'S THE CONCERN
YOU'RE HEARING HERE IS ABOUT
THAT RIA. IF I CAN JUST ADD ONE
OTHER THING. THE BOTH THE I AM
AND DAY HAD ENERGY DEAD MARKET
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE
VOLUNTARY AND THE REST OF THE
WEST AND- THERE ARE ENTITIES
THAT ARE ABLE TO SORT OF STEP
IN AND STEP OUT. DAY BY DAY. ON
RTO IS ON ALL IN SO IT REALLY
IS PLANNING JOINT BECAUSE WE'RE
DURING TRANSMISSION PLANNING
JOINTLY. AND WE ARE DISPATCHING
THE SYSTEM. SO I THINK.
ULTIMATELY TO GET THE MOST OUT
OF THIS. HAVING A SYSTEM WHERE
WE DO HAVE COMMITMENT BY ALL
THE PLAYERS WOULD BE MORE
VALUABLE THERE'S A QUESTION OF
HOW MUCH MORE VALUABLE. THANK
YOU. I AM SORRY IF I MADE YOU
REPEAT YOURSELF A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION WE HAD AND-
YOU SEEM TO BE ALIGNED IN. OUR
CHALLENGES ARE OPPORTUNITIES
AND KIND OF AN APPROACH. OF
MOVING FORWARD THAT THAT GIVES
US SOME WAY OF LOOKING AT THIS.
WITH SOME OPTIONS SO I
APPRECIATED. IT ANYBODY WANT TO
RE DIRECT BEFORE I GO TO THE-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE. LET ME ASK PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE NOMINEES ANY
ANYONE OR ANY OR ALL THREE OR
ANY COMBINATION. PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU WILL GIVE ME
YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF AND
MEMBERS JOHN WHITE FOR THE
CENTER FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
RENEWABLE TECHNOLOGIES WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ALL THREE.
CANDIDATES WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE ABELSON AND- A CAN TESTIFY
AS TO HIS ROLE WITH REGARD TO
THE SITUATION OXNARD. OF
INNOVATION AND LEADERSHIP HAS
REALLY WHAT. MARKED THE SERVICE
OF THESE APPOINTEES AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- OF. OF GIVING
THEM YOUR CONSIDERATION AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. BOB
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO
LENNY HUNTER ON BEHALF OF EDF
RENEWABLES IN SUPPORT OF ALL
THREE CANDIDATES TODAY A
SPECIAL THANKS TODAY FOR HIS
CONTINUED. UP SUPPORT AND
DOGGETT APPROACH TO MAKING SURE
THE RENEWABLES ACTUALLY HAPPEN
ON OUR GREAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WELCOME THANK YOU A CHANCE
MONEY JONES REPRESENTING THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
WHO REPRESENTED A UTILITY SCALE
SOLAR WIND GEOTHERMAL BIOMASS
AND SOME SMALL HYDRO AS WELL IS
THE CLEAN NATURAL GAS THAT'S
UTILIZED IN THE STATE. BUT TO
GET THE LIGHTS ON WIND THE SUN
IS SHINING WHICH IS NIGHTLY AND
OCCASIONALLY WHEN WINDOWS BLOW
WE SUPPORT ALL THREE OF THESE
CANDIDATES SOME OF THEM I'VE
DONE MISTER OLSON I'VE KNOWN
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS. MR
BOARD SHOULD FOR TWENTY AND
MISS LESLEE I I'VE I MET DURING
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
WOULD VETTING THESE CANDIDATES
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT THE
GUYS SO ACTUALLY DOES IS
RELIABILITY THAT IS PRIMARY
MISSION. AND IT'S DONE A VERY
GOOD JOB OF BEING ABLE TO TAKE
THE VERY INTERESTING CHALLENGES
WITH RESPECT TO HOW ARE A
HOWEVER RESOURCE BASE IS
SHIFTING AND BIG BASICALLY
CONTINUE TO. DELIVER RELIABLE
PRODUCTS SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO BASICALLY. CONFIRM ALL
THREE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MANAGER
I'M VERY MONNING WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
CESSATION WE REPRESENT THE OF
PUBLICLY ON ELECTRIC AND WATER
UTILITIES ACROSS THE STATE IN.
TURN AND MEMBERS WE SUPPORT ALL
THREE CANDIDATES FOR THEIR
CONFIRMATION WE'RE PUBLICLY
OWNED AND NOT FOR PROFIT ARE
OUR CONCERNS ARE ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY AND RELIABILITY.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO REACH
THE- ARE TWENTY FORTY FIVE
GOALS WE NEED TO HAVE A BALANCE
OF ALL THREE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH. ALL THREE OF
THESE CANDIDATES AS THEY AFTER
THEY'RE ON THE OTHER THINK I
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME. THE
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT OF GERMAN ALL SINCE
CONFIRMATION FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT WERE SO WELL
STATED BY SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU. HI WELCOME. REVENUE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. AT TODD
TRODDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF ALTAR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THEO PALE SERVICE AND CAL PINE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ALL THREE
APPOINTEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ
WITH UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MISTER OLSON THANKS
THANK YOU. PERSONAL GET US HERE
ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY IN SUPPORT OF ALL THREE
NOMINATIONS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
VICTORIA ROM WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THREE NOMINEES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TIFFANY
PHANTOM HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EFFICIENCY AND REIMAGINE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF MISTER
OLSON FOR CONFIRMATION. Q. OKAY
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S THERE
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
WELL THAT'S A GOOD SIGN OUR
THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU SENATOR
OFFICE MOVE THE NOMINATION
MADAM SECRETARY. SENATORS BATES
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH
AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE ATKINS HI.
AND THAT IS FOUR ZERO WITH AN
ABSENCE OF CONGRATULATIONS
RECONFIRMED CONFIRMED THANK YOU
.
WE WILL MOVE INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION AS THE. ROOM CLEARS AND
WE SHOULD BE SOON DONE. YEAH